les salles de spectacle ont été parmi
les premiers lieux à fermer leurs portes
en raison de la crise sanitaire des
mesures qui ont eu comme conséquence un
coup d'arrêt brutal de la saison en
cours
à montigny le bretonneux le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines estime la
perte financière sur les recettes de sa
billetterie à 150000 euros
pour l'instant on essaie de ne procéder
pas à pas l'or par exemple l'âge je
travaille ce matin avant que que vous
mmes à pied sur la possibilité de
décaler certains des spectacles à la fin
juin mais on travaille quasiment que sur
des hypothèses c'est ça qui est très
compliquée en fait avec cette période
c'est qu'on travaille avec des
hypothèses diverses
là par exemple hypothèse c'est de se
dire que le théâtre pourrait rouvrir au
public vers la semaine du 22 juin où la
semaine du 29 juin où quelqu'un on
essaie de décaler certains spectacles
prévus en mai au mois de juin
parmi les personnes directement impacté
les artistes attrape la troupe de déclic
théâtre compte sept salariés permanents
et une trentaine d'intermittents du
spectacle tout au long de l'année
il venait tout juste de présenter leur
dernier spectacle au public
écran noir quand la crise sanitaire a
débuté
l'arrêt net des activités a soulevée dès
le départ pour nous la question des
salaires des intermittents du spectacle
qui sont trouvés privés de de travail du
jour au lendemain
privés de salaire et privés d'heure
puisque puisque le calcul des heures est
très important pour le statut et les
renouvellements despatie des
intermittents du spectacle est-ce que
malgré tout vous gardez de vous lire les
sourires j'imagine on va garder
effectivement le le sourire et le bon
marché positive la crise sanitaire qui
est d'ailleurs source d'inspiration pour
de nombreux artistes confiné dans son
appartement à vélizy l'imitateur stan
bennett partagent chaque jour sur les
réseaux sociaux une vidéo
ceux ci
[Musique]
l'humour choisit également parle
yvelinoise laurie père et faute de
pouvoir être sur la scène du théâtre
république à paris elles partagent
régulièrement ses conseils confinement
et sa vision de la situation
je passe vous rappeler à quelques temps
on était quand même en train de se faire
livrer de la neige dans les pyrénées
et là il y en a un il a fait ben voilà
la goutte de trop la bavure
il a bouffé un pangolin et on en est là
coronavirus besoin comme la course où
nous rend idiot les saumons d'élevage
sont souvent theuriau l'estomac des
vaches muninn à vélo ou est ce qui ad
nous nicolas lau